what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into I guess really kind
of continuing our discussion on the
Marvel cosmic landscape infinity war
different things like that I want to
switch over to the character of Gamora
and I want to offer this this
explanation on her because we've never
really talked about Gamora in depth
we've talked about stories that she's
been in but we've never really done a
character explanation on her so Gamora
first appeared back in strange tales
issue number 180 in 1975 and she was
created by jim Starlin now in our video
about Adam warlock we had talked about
how his character had gone through these
sort of phases which is to say he was
originally introduced in Fantastic Four
and then of course he appeared in Thor
in the early days and those two stories
the Fantastic Four in Thor he was only
known as him he was created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby and the idea was to
introduce warlock as a character who was
kind of figuring out the nature of
things he was very much a newborn being
who had these almost you know nyama
'putin abilities you know it's really
kind of hinted to that he could be
virtually unstoppable if he ever
achieved his full potential now of
course following these two stories in
Fantastic Four and Thor he was rolled
over into his own solo series in the
power of warlock one through eight and
of course this dealt with the idea of
his character kind of being revamped
turned into a messianic character the
issue with this was that with issue
number eight the power of warlock was
canceled and then effectively jim
Starlin took over the character in
strange tales issues 180 181 going
through into the newly launched warlock
series which was just kind of continuing
on the numbering so it was warlock 9
through 15 and the whole idea behind
this was that gomorrah was part and
parcel to this whole attempt by jim
Starlin to expand the Marvel cosmic
landscape remember back in the 1970s and
1980s really going into like Infinity
Gauntlet in the 1990s while you did have
cosmic characters out there it wasn't
really a unified thing there was no real
like greater Marvel cosmology and there
wasn't really like you know this sort of
coherent system where it all sort of
comes together and at any point in time
you can see all these different solo
series instead you just kind of had
these characters who would just be out
there you would have quasar and you
would have marvel of the Kree and he'd
have these stories here and there you
might have some Galactus stories you
might have some Silver Surfer stories
and that was really about it the works
of jim Starlin and the reason why they
were so important back during the 1970s
in 1980s was because he laid the
foundation for what writers like Dan
Abnett would do later on whether
all these different cosmic characters
and they would consolidate them all back
into a singular cohesive unit that would
be the Marvel cosmic landscape and so
with the character of Gamora again
because she was part and parcel to this
this really deals with what a lot of
Adam warlock fans refer to as The Magus
saga now this really kind of picked up
in strange tales 180 in 181 running into
the Warlock second iteration of his solo
series and the whole idea behind this
was that jim Starlin had introduced the
idea that we're out of warlock had the
soul stone that it's harm would
eventually come when he would be
corrupted by it
he would basically be driven insane and
he would eventually become a being
called The Magus who would have an
amazing afro and the whole idea behind
this was that the Magus would form
something called the universal Church of
truth and the universal Church of truth
would simply just kind of be held bent
on universal domination that's really
all it would do those individuals who
didn't convert to the universal Church
of truth were eradicated those who did
were inducted into its ranks and
bolstered the population of the church
allowing it to swell a number and expand
its ever increasing role now with
regards to Magus himself because he was
effectively from the future and he was a
future version of what Adam warlock
would be this allowed jim Starlin to
kind of maneuver the pieces in the
chessboard so to speak to kind of cook
the books a bit in order to introduce
characters who normally wouldn't have a
reason to be introduced for gamora's
introduction an issue number 180 and 181
there wasn't really a whole lot given
about her initially in fact it would be
about three or four issues before she
would actually get an explanation and
stat she somebody just showed up saying
that she was looking for Adam warlock
now of course by this point Adam warlock
had been taken prisoner by the universal
Church of Truth they were really kind of
putting him through the paces to ensure
that the conditioning would go through
and eventually he would become the
maggots basically guaranteeing his
existence but because of the fact that
warlock had basically been taken by the
universal Church it simply meant for
that you know pip the troll who had
actually been introduced in strange
tales 179 I think it was had basically
just sort of been off on his own now of
course the more running into him was one
of these interesting scenarios because
occasionally she would report back to
you and communicate with someone called
the master and that was really about it
but one of the first things Stalin
fleshed out is that Gamora is the
deadliest woman in the galaxy that if it
really comes down to it no one's going
to be able to stop her now when she
initially arrives alongside pip the
troll to the universal Church one of the
Black Knights who were really kind of
like the soldiers the foot soldiers of
the universal Church immediately
recognizes Gamora for what she is
absolutely begins to panic and that's
when jim Starlin starts to get into this
idea there's a lot more to her character
than we're initially being led on to
believe and so because of the fact that
we ultimately have this showdown that
took place between Adam warlock and
between Magus and basically had led to
the idea that Adam warlock was
essentially thrown into a place called a
pit where he was going to be driven
insane until he actually became the
Magus it effectively meant that Gomorrah
wasn't able to save Adam warlock and
kill the Magus the other half of this
was that Gomorrah initially wasn't
really sensed by the Magus meaning he
couldn't actually see her this was
explained in warlock issue number 10 and
the reason why is because of the fact
that we end up learning the master that
Gomorrah is reporting to him is actually
Thanos himself and the whole idea behind
this it really kind of comes in her
origin story which is a little strange
and it actually is actually a fix later
on down the line but it's simply this
idea that at some point in the future
gomorrah's race called as in row beerus
i think is what they're called they were
basically met by the universal Church of
Truth and the universal Church tried to
convert them to their own belief system
and the Zen well beerus declined the
result was that all of them were
eradicated with the exception of
gomorrah but because Thanos realized
that Adam warlock would become the Magus
Thanos took the character of Gomorrah
brought her back to the modern day
effectively taking her out of an
alternate reality and it's sort of hoped
that by virtue of doing so that she
would kind of exist outside of time
quote-unquote meaning that Magus
wouldn't actually be able to see her
she'd effectively be a ghost as far as
he's concerned
now of course Magus did since her
presence but chose to ignore her because
the most important thing was to focus on
Adam warlock
but with Gamora pip the troll and Thanos
working alongside each other to free
Adam warlock and then going on to the
defeat that Magus thus ends in issue
number 15 the Magus saga basically
meaning he's defeated now of course at
the conclusion of all this it also ties
in the idea that Adam warlock will never
be able to eliminate the soul Jam he'll
always have to keep it because it's
basically kind of absorbed a fraction of
a soul for the most part and so he's
part and parcel to the gym itself that's
why the soul gym really kind of goes
hand in hand with Adam warlock because a
part of his soul is effectively inside
the soul stone he can never really get
rid of it who'd be like getting rid of
an arm or a leg or something like that
he would lose part of himself with a
process now again because of the fact
that this was an attempt by jim Starlin
to sort of build this cosmic landscape
this story as it appeared in strange
tales 179 through 181 running all the
way up from warlock issue number nine to
issue number 15 all
so ran part and parcel to a series of
events that were unfolding in the
Captain Marvel stories and these all
basically came to a head in Avengers
annual issue number seven and marveled -
and one I cannot remember what issue it
was but it was basically the first time
fan oohs grabbed the Infinity stones and
the idea was that the intention of
Thanos in defeating or at least seeing
the defeat of The Magus was basically to
form an alliance of sorts without a
warlock so he could steal Adam warlock
soul stone and so the intention of danos
was to basically merge all the Infinity
stones together and then form a giant
stone and blink out all the stars in the
universe now again this is in the early
days of Thanos as character and before
he learned about the Infinity Gauntlet
and so because of the fact that Thanos
had basically tasked Gomorrah with out
lying herself and really being a
bodyguard of sorts to Adam warlock in
order to make sure he stays safe so the
Thanos could steal the soul stone when
he needs to this created an alliance of
sorts that jim Starlin built on and so
what this meant was that following the
defeat of tano's basically Adam warlock
retreating to soul world Gamora went
along with him as well as pip Patrol and
what this did is it actually fast
forwarded a bit and it took us into the
story of Infinity Gauntlet
now a couple thing to keep in mind here
the transportation of the essences of
gomorrah and pit patrol and Adam warlock
that was really done by virtue of the
fact that their physical forms had quote
unquote died so in order to kind of keep
their essences alive they were just
transported to soul world and again soul
world is just kind of a place where
people who were formerly enemies or even
friends of Adam warlock they all just
kind of lived in a peaceful coexistence
you know means like crate or and
different things like that but the whole
idea behind this is that it actually
just kind of allowed jim Starlin to sit
them on the back burner for a time to
basically say oK we've finished The
Magus saga let's take a more let's take
pit patrol let's take out a Morlock and
let's just sit him back here until we
bring them back now again because of the
fact that a lot of these things dealt
with stories like daños quest and so on
and so forth continuing this cosmology
and kind of building up to the Infinity
Gauntlet story the return of gomorrah
pit patrol and adam warlock really came
by way of a visit from the silver surfer
who was basically responding to the idea
that Thanos had learned about the
Infinity Gauntlet he had gained all the
Infinity stones and he had effectively
become God and so it was really a silver
surfer in a position where he was is
kind of traversing the spaceways trying
to find help wherever he could now of
course this ultimately led into Silver
Surfer crash-landing into the sanctum
sanctorum of Doctor Strange and then
this kind of set things in motion for
the main infant
Gauntlet story but the coolest thing
about this was that again because jim
Starlin was writing so much of this
there really isn't a whole lot of
deviation in terms of stories that were
done about gomorrah in terms of things
that you know involve your character you
know with anybody else really taking up
the reins instead what this did is it
went into the Infinity Gauntlet story
proper which as we all pretty much know
I saw the return of Adam warlock pit
patrol and Gomorrah they were simply
thrown into the bodies of three deceased
people it allowed jim Starlin to return
them to the Marvel Universe with more
power than they had before and then that
event unfolded as most all of us are
used to now of course because of the
fact that Infinity Gauntlet ended with
the defeat of Thanos of the hands of
nebula and then ultimately out of
warlock taking the gauntlet for himself
in the aftermath to the Infinity
Gauntlet story effectively Adam warlock
was put on trial by the cosmic entities
and there was this idea that because
Adam warlock didn't really look to
replace eternity as the most powerful
being in the universe ultimately the
Living Tribunal second only to the one
above all basically shut down the
Infinity Gauntlet disabled the Infinity
stones and then told Adam warlock to
disperse them evenly so that the the
Infinity stones could never he brought
back together and if they were it
wouldn't matter because the Infinity
Gauntlet would never work and so this
led directly into a line of comics
called warlock and the Infinity watch
now warlock in the infinity watch was a
very big deal when it came to the
character of Gamora because this was
designed in a lot of ways to effectively
be a team book with jim Starlin riding
warlock in the infinity watch between
issues 1 to 31 running between 1992 to
1994 roughly the whole idea behind this
was that where the story was for the
most part monthly becoming bimonthly
during the events of infinity war and
kind of crossing over with those stories
a lot of the background that came with
Gamora really covered her early days
alongside Thanos you know when they
don't have basically taken her from the
now-extinct is in well beerus and then
took her under his wing and began going
through and teaching her the kind of
things she needed to know a lot of this
dealt with the idea that gomorrah was
kind of learning her place for the most
part it was this concept that gomorrah
would go forward that Thanos would
really be kind of cold to her in a lot
of different ways he saw her as a weapon
and he groomed her that way there was
actually a particular story and I do not
remember which issue it is and warlock
in the infinity watch I want to say it's
issue number 5 issue number 4 or 5 or
something like that but it's basically a
point whereby she goes on a mission and
actually ignores Thanos and the result
is that she's graphically assaulted by a
hand
the thugs Thanos kills them all and then
gives her cybernetic implants and that's
when it starts to go into the idea that
Thanos had made these genetic
modifications to Gamora to basically
enhance her ability so that where she
gained her digits fighting experience
where she was one of the deadliest
people out there in terms of all manner
of weapons use and different things like
that that Thanos had modified her using
cybernetic implants to push her that
much further now while jim Starlin
focused on a lot of elements with
regards to the background of Gamora in
the modern day there were also a lot of
things that were designed to kind of
build her character in the presence
because in truth when it came to 1990s
comics especially with characters like a
more of the cosmic landscape again we're
talking about uncharted waters for the
most part and because the largest
emphasis for Marvel was put on earth
bound superheroes it sort of allowed jim
Starlin to kind of get away with things
that we wouldn't normally expect and so
a lot of the things that he developed
were things like a potential romance
between Gamora and Adam warlock
ultimately it didn't work out initially
removing you know Gamora from the
infinity watch just to see what would
happen with regards to changing up
different members of the team the idea
that she was experiencing some measure
of clairvoyance II it was different
things like that that were designed to
kind of experiment with her character II
was literally this sort of Ketchel it
was grabbing all these different themes
and seeing what fans enjoyed now at the
same time this also dealt with you know
really jim Starlin kind of going off and
riding these various spin-off infinity
stories and infinity of this was really
one of the early 2000 stories that
introduced a character named atleta who
basically went on to become a kind of
custodian of a multiverse which is a
very ambiguous role it's something to do
with making sure the multiverse never
sinks into oblivion or something along
those lines it's not a fully fleshed out
ideology it's just one of those
instances where Thanos kind of just
created a multiversal being just to
explain the nature of the story but I
dealt with the idea that because the
romance was actually forming between
Adam warlock
and Gamora it wasn't necessarily a
happily ever after kind of thing like
riding them off into the into a world of
enjoyment so much as it was just kind of
leaving things you know to a point where
so I D else could kind of pick up the
slack and the result was that when it
came to the Mora and Adam warlock with
that leather standing in and basically
becoming the new custodian of the
multiverse what it meant is someone had
to raise her outside of all space and
time to basically ensure that she could
understand what it meant to play that
role as what effectively allowed jim
Starlin to write the characters of
Gamora
Adam warlock out of the main Marvel
Universe and into basically a litany of
other stories that he wanted to write
involving those characters that wouldn't
really see any major changes or
ramifications and kind of see them
removed for the main Marvel line of
comics and so for quite some time really
I'd say about four or five years between
2002 and 2006 there wasn't really a
whole lot going on with Gamora in the
main Marvel Universe all you really had
was her appearing in these various
infinity stories and these various you
know cosmic stories were written by jim
Starlin marvel the end different things
like that the reason why this matters is
because as we've said in 2006 writer Dan
Abnett came along and basically said
okay let's grab all these characters
these these cosmic characters who have
been evolved over the years by one
writer or another and we're gonna bring
them all together and the launch pad he
used to introduce those things into this
larger landscape was the story of
annihilation now where annihilation was
designed to again be this sort of coming
together of these various forces with
regards to you know cosmic beings and
really cosmic entities and different
things like that for the character of
Gamora there wasn't a whole lot going on
with her instead she just kind of
blended in with a lot of other people
who were doing various things I mean
annihilation dealt with a nihilist and
the annihilation wave and all those
different things spreading across the
universe and trying to wipe out all life
and so on and so forth she fought
alongside the ufn the United Front of
Nova or similar Mo's like I think it's
what it's called
as far as annihilation go she was just
one of a multitude of characters there
in truth it almost seemed like the days
of focusing explicitly on demora had
long since passed but in truth Dan
Abnett and company actually brought her
back into the fold when it came to the
Phalanx and the annihilation conquest
story now of course annihilation
conquest up with the idea of Ultron
basically trying to conquer the universe
it was an incredibly good story but what
Ultron would do by way of the Phalanx is
because the family she just kind of like
the board from Star Trek is really the
best way to think about it because
they're just kind of like this
spacefaring cybernetic race the idea is
that they would basically just kind of
assimilate every single beam they came
across but those individuals who
possessed a heightened level of skill
whether it was hand-to-hand combat or
whether it was the ability to manipulate
energy they would basically be the
select and what this would mean is they
would be you know assimilated into the
Phalanx but they would be allowed some
of autonomy meaning they'd be able to go
out and do their own thing but it would
all be done for the purpose of expanding
the failings where Gomorrah was
basically he's assimilated by the
failings group itself what this meant
was that it allowed her to kind of go
forward for the purpose of trying to
bring in Richard Reiter and that's
really where a lot of the development
after jim Starlin began to take place
when it came to her character this idea
that there was a kind of attractiveness
to her the element of the character that
you saw in guardians of the galaxy in
the movie for the most part the idea
that she had somewhat of a softer side
all that stuff was really fleshed out in
the later works of jim Starlin and
heavily done by the work of Dan Abnett
in the in the annihilation conquest
story now of course ultimately she was
freed from her captivity this is
romantic tension between herself and
Nova really began to sort of fade away
and the two of them went their own
separate ways but following the events
of annihilation conquest because of the
fact that Dan Abnett is sort of put you
know pulled this huge story together the
saw this coming together of all these
heroes of just how dire the situation
could be with regards to what would
happen if things really went awry in the
universe the idea was to begin breaking
things down into smaller scales and so
where a lot of those saw things like
Richard Ryder for example is the last
surviving member of the Minova core
basically going on and having the nodal
force all to himself trying to reform
the Nova Corps different things like
that it also focus with the creation of
the guardians of the galaxy now the
guardians of the galaxy had existed in
terms of guardians of the galaxy 3000
but in terms of the modern-day team that
you guys think of that wasn't really
formed until after the events of
annihilation conquest and it was a lot
of these characters who had kind of been
brought together and simply said we need
to have a team that will basically
safeguard the universe should things
begin to go awry but the whole idea
behind focusing on Gamora as part of the
guardians was to kind of look at her and
say how does she fit in in a situation
like this how does it work when someone
who's basically a lone wolf for the most
part kind of a lone warrior is really
brought in to work alongside a team and
it was interesting because there were a
lot of funny moments when it came to
bickering when it came to infighting all
those different concepts sort of putting
her in a position where she was
constantly trying to break away from her
history with Thanos going out into forge
your own path different things like that
a lot of these themes that have been
built on over the years we're really
starting to come to a head with regards
to these particular stories now again
because of the fact that you know Dan
admits work only went on for so long and
things like guardians of the galaxy vol
3 by Brian Michael
Bendis began the process of coming in
and making some changes were Kimura was
a major focal point of the team for
quite some time and truth under Brian
Michael Bendis and his relatively short
run the idea of guardians of the galaxy
for him was doing things like expanding
on star-lord you know Jason of spartax
and the whole idea that earth had
basically been blocked off that nobody
was allowed to go to earth for the most
part gomorrah didn't really play a huge
part there were some funny moments you
know when iron man showed up join the
guardians of the galaxy for a time you
know he and gomorrah kind of got
together and she was a lot more than
iron man could handle and when it comes
to these funny little moments and things
like that it is cool and it is pretty
interesting you know you had small
little moments here and there where her
character would become relatively
popular and great things would happen
but for the most part she was largely
just kind of now a background character
in the Marvel cosmic and that's one of
the benefits but also one of the
drawbacks that you find when there is
this sort of coming together of all
these different themes that there's very
little room to have characters who
aren't wildly huge who want massively
significant they're not legacy
characters and make them important
star-lord is important because he was
effectively the leader of the guardians
of the galaxy characters like fan OHS
were important because of stories like
Infinity Gauntlet infinity war infinity
a best-of and things like that but for
characters like Gamora
she was just another person who was
there as the result was that going into
businesses run with the introduction of
Angela from the spawn universe grabbing
these different concepts rolling Gamora
over it was constantly reminding people
that you know Gamora is pretty dangerous
she is a formidable assassin but for the
most part aside from rescuing Abigail
brand or something along those lines or
maybe you know pairing up with agent
venom when he joined guardians that was
really about it now stories like black
vortex were cool when she basically
gained these sort of cosmic powers but
again by 2012 2013 2014 Marvel was
winding down Marvel wasn't really
building characters up for the most part
Marvel was moving towards a direction of
Secret Wars and you know with Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
so on and so forth and so the collapse
of the multiverse was happening things
are basically beginning to come to a
close and where Gamora had near the
power of the black for text that kind of
segue directly into Secret Wars and then
of course it came out with all-new
all-different marvel as she basically
was powered down back to her normal self
and so following this there really
wasn't much done with her care
at all and that's one of the things that
people were so upset about is because
Gomorrah does have a pretty interesting
history and for a person who's so
dangerous and a person who's so capable
a lot of fans looked at her and said
well she's kind of wasted here she had a
miniseries of source that revisited her
past and dealt with the idea of Thanos
taking her and you know allowing her to
wipe out you know the the remnants of
you know individuals who were so kind of
floating around and you know get revenge
for the fact that her race was
obliterated and different things like
that but for the most part the days of
gomorrah being this major focal point
with regards to her relationships
without a warlock or her relationship
with nova that was long since gone so
again going forward I mean with her
being in infinity war as part of
guardians of the galaxy the actual movie
itself because of the fact that she
seems to be playing more of a prominent
role within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and because lots being done to
build up her character to make her so
dangerous and most likely her and nebula
will end up facing off against then I
was during the events of infinity war I
wouldn't be surprised if around May
April June we start to see these
different publications come out I
wouldn't be surprised there's more
information forthcoming about her
character but for right now she's just
another one of these coming book
concepts it was designed by a writer
somewhere who rose to prominence for a
short amount of time and then ultimately
just kind of blended in with everybody
else and just sort of falls in rank and
file but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later please
[Music]